[Musik]
hey leute wir haben heute die passende
antwort auf die frage was koche ich nur
heute mit wem man es endlich hamza und
mich verwundern wenn ich in der wir form
spreche obwohl ihr mich seht wie auch
immer ich habe hier überschaubare
zutaten denn wir machen eine klassische
nudelpfanne bzw ich verarbeite weiter
als auflauf ich über bug das ganze aber
das könnte ich hier bei dem rezept
selber entscheiden wie ihr das macht und
hier sind die zutaten
ich habe einmal rinder hackfleisch
rapsöl motto relation er über überbacken
außerdem habe ich hier zwiebeln und
knoblauch passierte tomaten sahne da
nehme ich gerne die fettarme variante
ein paar gewürze kurkuma carey ein
bisschen chili kreuzkümmel und zucker
und natürlich die klassiker salz und
pfeffer und was ich auch schon
vorbereitet habe
das sind hier die nudeln die müsst ihr
ganz einfach nur al dente kochen nach
packungsanleitung und wir gehen jetzt
rüber zu anderen fahne und dann zeige
ich euch wie wir weiter vorgehen
das öl habe ich in meiner beschichteten
pfanne schon erhitzt und da gebe ich
jetzt die zwiebeln mit dazu und auch
schon die knoblauchzehe ihr könnt
natürlich auch zwei knoblauchzehen
nehmen ich bin ein fan von knoblauch
aber wir machen es heute nicht nur einer
und ihr könnt es dann so ungefähr ein
bis zwei minuten lang auf mittlerer
hitze andünsten und dann kommt das
hackfleisch dazu
[Musik]
so meine lieben nachdem wir das fleisch
schön durchgebraten habe das ist so
ungefähr 45 minuten gedauert auf stufe
sieben von neun gibt ihr alle anderen
zutaten mit dazu bis auf euren
mozzarella das kommt gleich erst zum
einsatz
das heißt passierte tomaten die fettarme
sahne und die gewürze und dann lass dir
das noch mal fünf minuten beim köcheln
und dabei immer wieder umrühren
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich die gekochten nudeln noch
dazu gegeben und es hat mir zwei
möglichkeiten entweder ihr verspeist das
so denn so ist es eigentlich auch schon
fertig oder ihr mögt es wie ich
überbacken dann gibt er das in einer
auflaufform die habe ich hier und dann
gibt er den käse eurer wahl darüber
bei uns ist es nutzer heute
[Musik]
den ofen habe ich gerade schon
vorgeheizt auf 200 grad ober und
unterhitze da gebe ich den jetzt nur so
lange rein bis der käse wirklich schön
schmidt das dürften zehn bis 15 minuten
sein und dann sehen wir uns auch schon
wieder einen dann können wir auch schon
essen
am besten passt dazu übrigens ein
schöner frischer salat und dann was
durch das ganz einfach schmecken so wie
wir beide gleich nachdem ihr die fotos
geschossen haben und dann hoffe ich
natürlich dass sie mir ein dörfchen nach
oben da last wenn euch das rezept
gefallen hat schreibt mir auf jeden fall
mein kommentar was jetzt sehen möchtet
zum herzhaften bereich gibt mir ja gerne
mal eure vorschläge rein und dann halte
ich mich da auch dran und dann hoffe ich
dass wir uns auch beim nächsten video
sehen dies eure ki gehen
[Musik]